We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P..
There's a really great question brought up
in today's voicemail.
Take a listen to this.
Hello, David.
I was watching your show today and listen
to your show.
And there was that interview with a gun rights
activist and Marjorie Taylor Green.
And I was just wondering if I'm a socialist,
why does everyone think that socialist or
anti-gun when, you know, Marx and Lenin and
Mao wrote explicitly, were explicitly pro-gun?
Do they just I mean, I know they're operating
that way, but they just fundamentally not
have any idea, I guess, what socialism is
or.
I don't know.
Yet this is a this is a really excellent question.
There is this reflexive inclusion whenever
people talk about socialist's wrongly and
again, there's almost no socialists in positions
of power in the United States.
It's a complete and total farce.
But you often hear about the socialists who
want to disarm you.
That is a completely non based in history
claim.
And there are lots of examples of this.
If you look back at an 1850 speech written
by Karl Marx and Engels, they say under no
pretext should arms and ammunition be surrendered.
Any attempt to disarm the workers must be
frustrated by force if necessary.
There are many socialist theorists who supported
armed workers in part of their support of
the proletariat, maintaining power, recognizing
that maybe the gun would be a useful way for
them to gain power over the capitalists.
Mao under Mao, villages, factories, all sorts
of different units.
You know, discrete units were expected and
encouraged to have armed militias that were
self organized and were they had weapons under
Lenin.
Lenin wrote on disarmament, where Lenin said
an oppressed class which does not strive to
learn to use arms to acquire arms, only deserves
to be treated like slaves.
Lenin's perspective, as I understand it, is
having weapons prevents you from being treated
like a slave by the capitalists, by the employer,
by the owners of the means of production.
So not only do they not I mean, yes, if you're
wondering does the right understand X, the
the answer is probably not.
And not only do they misunderstand what socialism
is and who is a socialist, they very casually
and wrongly talk about anti-gun socialists
when historically there is much pro-gun sentiment
among some of the most important and notable
socialist Marxist figures in history.
But I don't think they care.
I don't think watching this clip is going
to change their minds.
They'll just keep repeating the same stuff
on the bonus show today, we will talk about
Jeff Bezos planning to step down as Amazon
CEO.
We will talk about the capital rioters quickly
selling each other out to try to lower their
own possible prison sentences.
And we will talk about Oregon decriminalizing
possession of drugs.
A huge step in Oregon.
We will talk about the implications.
Oregon as someone is somewhat someone I know
says it, but I say Oregon.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom to get instant
access.